we're on problem 32 32 what are the
solutions to the equation 1 plus 1 over
x squared is equal to 3 over X so at
first this looks like a pretty daunting
equation you have these X's in the
denominator and x squared in the
denominator but I think we can simplify
it if we can just get rid of these X
Squared's in denominator the easiest way
to do that is to multiply everything by
x squared so let's multiply both sides
of this equation by x squared and then
we'll get CX squared times 1 is x
squared x squared times 1 over x squared
well that's just 1 and then x squared
times 3 over X that's 3x squared over X
x squared or divided by X is just X so
that is equal to 3x we could subtract 3x
from both sides and you get x squared
minus 3x plus 1 is equal to 0 this is a
simple quadratic and it's not obvious
that you can factor it in fact yeah two
numbers when you multiply them equal 1
and that when you when you add them
equal minus 3 I'm guessing it might even
be imaginary when I but not be imaginary
but is just a strange number so let's
use the quadratic equation when in doubt
use a quadratic equation so minus B this
is B right B is this 3 right there the
night negative 3 right B is negative 3
so minus B is going to be plus 3 plus or
minus the square root of B squared minus
3 squared is 9 minus 4 times a which is
1 times C which is wants us minus 4 all
of that over 2a a is 1 so it's just over
2 C that is equal to 3 halves plus or
minus is that the square root of 5 over
2 I just separated these out because
look any of the choices and it seems
like they did that so you could say
that's three halves plus square root of
5 over 2 or 3 halves minus the square
root of 5 over 2 and I just did that
because it seems like that's how they
write it and that is choice a next
problem 33
33 I think this one actually might be
good to copy and paste the problem let
me see if I can do this okay there are
two numbers with the following
properties let me write down the
properties and let me copy and paste it
from for you okay I've copied it let me
go here and then I've pasted it for you
all right now
so the second number so there's two
numbers of the file purpose the second
number is three more than the first
number so let's say s for second number
and F for first number so the second
number the second number is three more
than the first number so a second number
is equal to the first number plus three
that's from statement one and then the
product of the two numbers is nine more
than the sum so the product of the two
numbers product of the two numbers
that's s times F s times F is nine more
nine plus their sum plus s plus F plus C
we have two equations in two unknowns
this is not linear because I'm
multiplying these two variables but I
think we should be able to to solve them
one way or the other so let's see we
have what s is equal to so let's just
substitute that back into this equation
so let's say that s is equal to F plus 3
so if we substitute for these s's we get
F plus 3 times F is equal to 9 plus F
plus 3 right instead of an S F plus 3
and then plus F see if we can supply
this F times F is f squared plus 3 F is
equal to 9 plus 3 is 12 plus 2 F plus 2
F let's see subtract two from both sides
you get F squared plus F is equal to 12
subtract 12 you get F squared plus F
minus 12 is equal to 0 and this one
looks factorable I don't have to take
out the quadratic equation let's see
is f c/f plus four times F minus three
right because when you multiply those
you get negative twelve and you add
those you get plus one so that is equal
to zero so in order for this to be true
one of one or both of these have to be
equal to zero so if F plus four is equal
to zero f plus four is equal to zero
that means that F is f could be equal to
minus four if F minus three is equal to
zero then that says that F could be
three so through F could be minus four
or three now s is f plus three so if
we're dealing with the minus four
scenario if F is equal to minus four
then what is s then s is going to be
minus four plus 3 and s is going to be
equal to minus one and that if F is
equal to 3 then s is equal to 6 so let's
see if we see either of these
combinations minus 4 minus 1 that's
choice B excellent all right problem 34
problem 34 let me see
maybe I should copy and paste these
these word problems so we can see how we
parse the problems so I've copied it now
let me go here then pasted it Jenny is
solving the equation x squared minus 8x
equals 9 by completing the square
what number should be added to both
sides of the equation to complete the
square so x squared minus 8x is equal to
9 and I wrote it with space for a reason
when you're completing the square you're
trying to turn the left-hand side of
this equation into some type of a
perfect square right so if it's a
perfect square I have two numbers and
it's the same number that when you add
them together when you add them together
you get minus 8 and when you square them
you should get something else right so
what's half of minus 8 half of minus 8
is minus 4 and if I add 6 so minus 4
squared is 16 so if I add 16 to both
sides I'm all set and why did that work
well now it's a perfect square this is
now X minus 4 squared is equal to 9 plus
625 they're not even asking us to solve
it they just want
we had to add to both sides so it's 16 D
and remember the whole logic here and
I've done a few videos on completing the
square is what number do I add here to
make this a perfect square and you say
okay I have a minus 8x so I take half of
this number right because the same
number add it to itself twice is going
to become minus 8 I take half of that
number and then I square it so half of
minus 8 is minus 4 and you square it you
get the 16 so I had 16 to both sides you
get this and you could actually solve
for this you know X minus 4 is plus or
minus 5 and you keep going and that's
actually where the quadratic equation
comes from anyway next problem 16 was
choice number D all right so they say
actually I'm gonna copy and paste this
entire problem here let's go here you
paste it here ok which of the following
most accurately describes a translation
of the graph ok y is equal to X plus 3
squared minus 2 to the graph y equals X
minus 2 squared plus 2 so this
translations and all that that's often
so the y translation it tends to be
pretty pretty easy to to figure out
because if I have some let me just draw
some example graph so if I had the graph
x squared the graph x squared looks
something like this
see if I can draw it the graph x squared
looks something like this right and
there's sex when x is equal to 0 we're
at our minimum point right and any other
value increases in these both direction
the graph of x squared plus 2 you're
shifting up right this is the graph of x
squared plus 2 you would shift it up by
2 and the graph of x squared minus 2 you
would shift down by 2 right this would
be x squared plus 2 and this would be x
squared minus 2 so the shift in the Y
Direction is very easy to see so if
we're going from something minus 2 if
we're going from something minus 2 to
plus 2 so we're going from minus 2 to
plus 2 we're going to be shifting it up
for right so that's always the easy one
to just eyeball and
figure out so we're definitely going to
be shifting from minus 2 to 2 so it's up
4 so it's either going to be choice a or
choice D the left/right shift is often a
little bit more hard for people to
visualize or to to at least internalize
but let's we'll give you an attempt if
this is the graph let's just go back to
this this is the graph of x squared this
yellow line right there right that's the
graph of x squared now let me ask you a
question what is the graph of x - I
don't know X minus 3 squared so does
this shift it down 3 2 3 2 the negative
direction or 3 to the positive direction
your intuition might say oh I'm
subtracting 3 when I had when I did that
you know minus 2 I shifted down but it's
actually the opposite here because you
have to think about for what value of x
am I going to have a 0 squared here
right and that happens when X is equal
to 3 so you can think of it this way now
when we're at this point when X is equal
to 3 it's the same thing as this point
when we have just x squared right
because when you put 3 in here this
whole expression becomes 0 and as you
get above 3 that's like going above 0
and as you go below 3 that's not going
below 0 so this graph will just get
shifted to the right by 3 right that's X
minus 3 shifts to the right by 3 X plus
3 would go in the other direction
because when X is minus 3 that's when it
would equal is your ivan run that down
so let's think about this we're going
from x plus 3 right so if this is x
squared x plus 3 is actually it would
look something let me do it in a
different color X plus 3 is actually
shifted to the left and the way I always
think about there's two ways to think
about it but the wide shift isn't
intuitive and the F shift might not be
if you have a plus 3 here you're
actually shifting in the downward
direction and the way to actually think
about that the intuition is when will
this whole expression equal 0 this whole
expression equals 0 when X is equal to
minus 3 so that's the point at which
you're getting 0 squared and I actually
didn't I'm when I'm drawing these graphs
I'm not doing the y shift here right so
this is going to be shifted to the left
3 this is going to be shifted to the
right by 2 so this
shifted to the left three and this is
shifted to the right by two to go from
this to this you're shifting to the
right by 5 right so you know X plus 3
squared is here so these grant the
actual graph X plus 3 squared minus 2 is
your it's going to be here right and
then your to go here you have a plus 2
so you're shifting the graph up by 4 and
then you're going to X minus 2 so this
graph right here is going to be up here
so you're shifting up by 4 and then
you're shifting to the right by 5
actually even if you're completely
confused whether you're shifting left or
right you get to say okay the difference
between plus 3 and minus 2 is 5 and
fives only there but you should you
should hopefully understand the problems
a little bit deeper than that anyway
I'll see you in the next video